Thank you Peter.
Hello and welcome to Accelerate genomics discovery
with SRA in the cloud.
My name is Yuriy and I and the SRA product
owner.
Before we get started with the webinar I want
you to take this poll.
This can tell me what your interests are in
this webinar.
I can tailor the message in the webinar on
the results here.
To make sure you get the most benefit out
of the webinar.
This is interactive poll so click on the screen.
In a few more seconds when everyone finishes
I will share results with everyone.
These are anonymized.
We will see the percentage for the options.
Great.
The major interest is why should I use SRA
data in the cloud and what technologies you
should be knowing about if you work in the
cloud.
Also the third topic of interest is you are
here to learn about cloud data and how to
use cloud.
So this webinar we will cover basics like
introduction to SRA and why it was moved to
the cloud.
The benefits you get from working in the cloud.
And of course, the tools available so far.
I will cover two case studies highlighting
cloud usage and provide you some information
and links of where to go to get started with
cloud resources.
Then we will have a Q&A session.
For those of you who don't know about SRA,
we are the Sequence Read Archive from NCBI.
We started in 2008 and pur primary mission
is to store and distribute next generation
sequencing data.
We accept all kinds of samples and all kinds
of data from different platforms.
The data is used in a variety of different
ways, from bioinformatics development to detection
of novel genes or microbial or viral species
even.
Why did we move to the cloud and why did we
do it 12 years after it started?
SRA has been growing exponentially year after
year.
We are over 14 petabytes of data at this point.
We have over 25 PB of user submitted files
that we can share with the community.
This is a lot of data.
Moving it from Bethesda, Maryland to anywhere
in the world is technically complex task and
also time-consuming.
Some of our users need to wait weeks or months
to just download data before they can do any
computational analysis.
Sometimes they discover some data they downloaded
is not useful and they need to download more.
This is a big barrier to doing quick analysis
on the data available.
Because there are great benefits, we want
to speed this up for the scientist community.
We went ahead and moved all 14 PB of SRA archival
data into the cloud.
From there you can get faster access to this
data.
You have powerful computer resources available
to you on demand.
You can easily expand the storage you are
using in the cloud so you are never waiting
to get more storage.
The cloud can be a great collaboration platform.
You can have your collaborators who may be
in different parts of the world log into the
same system and run the same pipelines and
look at the same results whenever they want.
You don't need to share those results individually
since everybody can login into the same server.
What we have done so far is we moved all of
the SRA archival format to the cloud.
That is available now.
We also started moving the user submitted
files which is roughly 25 PB more of data.
This is a new feature from SRA.
Instead of using archival format, you can
get to the files that we received from the
submitters.
We are always trying to be more efficient
and we want to be more efficient in the cloud.
We started producing contigs ourselves.
For now we only produce contigs for metegenomic
datasets, but we will be branching out to
RNA-seq genomic data sets and other types
as time goes on.
In order to access this data we updated our
API which is the SRA toolkit to work in the
cloud.
Instead of downloading data from Bethesda,
you will be accessing the data in our cloud
bucket.
This will speed up file access.
Another feature is we made available our metadata
in native cloud architecture.
For now this is just Google's BigQuery product
but this was a popular feature and we will
be moving all of this also to Amazons Athena,
now that we have received positive feedback
from the scientific community for this.
The case studies I wanted to highlight was
the NCBI virus discovery codathon.
Is a good example of cloud computing and the
benefits of cloud computing.
And our interaction with the cloud customer
who wanted to do things in the cloud natively.
The virus discovery codathon was started with
assumptions that there is a lot of viral data
available in meta-genomic data sets.
We brought several teams together and the
goal was to build some analysis and processing
pipelines for the data sets.
I won't be going into the details of the actual
code or what the results are but if you are
interested to read about it there is a publication
link you can follow.
https://www.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/pubmed/31527408
What I want to talk about is the pre-computation
that had to happen.
The assumption was that everybody would be
working on contigs and not raw data.
What SRA did is we took 140,000 runs of metagenomic
data sets that were 7 GB or smaller and we
built contigs from that.
This was either de novo assembly or guided
assembly.
We ended up building 3.9 billion contigs out
of the data.
In order to accomplish this we had to take
a two-step approach in computation.
The first one was using 500 nodes or servers
that were only 2 cores and 8GB in memory.
These are very small machines and some of
our cell phones are more powerful then this.
Of course we had to use larger machines for
the bigger files.
We used 100 machines and they had 96 cores
and 300 GB of RAM so they are big and powerful
machines.
Why did we do in the cloud?
It only took a couple weeks to do this in
the cloud.
We knew that if we try to do this internally
at NCBI on our high computing cluster it would
take us several months to do this.
You can see the bar change from a couple weeks
to several months of computing these contigs.
That is because SRA is not the only resource
at NCBI, we share the cluster with other resources.
Of course we would be queued up for computational
needs and this is something that some of you
might have faced before as well at your universities.
In the cloud all of the compute is what we
want and at our convenience.
What we learned from this experience is if
you want to get started faster in the cloud,
collaborations help.
So if you are collaborating with bioinformaticians
or programmers who are familiar with cloud
architecture that can help you get started
faster.
You can do this on your own.
But if you will do this on your own make sure
you start working in the small-scale first.
This will help you learn the different technologies.
If you are using known data sets that are
small and quick to compute on, you know what
the results should be.
As you get more comfortable with technology,
expand slowly.
Premature scaling to 100 or several hundred
machines, can lead to a large problem and
you won't know where to debug the problem.
It's important to scale slowly so you can
understand what's happening and if you run
into issues you can understand where to look
for the problems.
If you want to know what technologies we used
in our computation approach, that was Kubernetes,
Docker images, and there was scripting using
Python/BASH and Snakemake.
These are not the only technologies available.
Cloud technologies have competitors.
When you look into cloud technologies, some
other technologies may be a better fit for
you than the ones we used.
We tried to make our compute cheaper so we
try to use preemptable or spot instances depending
on which cloud vendor we used.
Those are cheaper options that you should
look into.
On the note section of this presentation I
added links to different resources that you
should check out.
After the webinar feel free to look at those
to get more information about any of these
different topics.
The community use case I wanted to highlight
was from researcher or who was interested
in the evolutionary relationship of microbial
communities and marine environments.
They were looking at marine metagenomic data
sets.
What they really wanted to do was build up
an automatic pipeline to look through SRA
data and the pipeline would run in the cloud.
They needed to be able to search for these
datasets quickly and efficiently.
They wanted to be able to fine-tune their
search parameters for these data sets.
The other need was to be able to know what
the microbial communities are within the data
sets.
For this we thought that BigQuery or Amazon
Athena products would be a good fit so we
started doing testing in the BigQuery.
We started out putting SRA metadata there.
We put sample information where the sample
was collected from and what depth and all
of this metadata that users provide.
We also had sequencing information of how
the sample was sequenced in terms of what
platforms were used.
Also statistic information such as the number
of bytes or the number of reads or bases available
in that data set.
This allowed the user to select high-quality
data sets from a particular platform or if
they wanted the run to be a certain size.
For the second need which was to know the
taxonomic content of the run, for that we
had to make the results from the SRA taxonomic
analysis tool available in BigQuery.
We haven't released this publicly yet as we
were still going through testing with a small
user group, but we will be releasing this
soon and this functionality will be copied
to Amazons Athena as well given more time.
With this data set they can identify what
microbial communities are available in a particular
run.
This is so they can fine tune their search
parameters even more.
Since this information is available quickly
from BigQuery, they can take the sequencing
information, they can take the search results
from taxonomic content and combine and take
the intersection of them, thereby getting
a small data set of runs that they can run
more expensive computational analysis on.
Getting started is fairly easy.
What you will get out of this will be customized
filtering for datasets that you want to emulate.
Obviously you will have powerful computing
available to you.
All you need is a laptop to login into the
cloud architecture.
If you are worried about costs, Amazon and
Google have free tiers available for you can
start playing around with this technology
and moving your analysis pipeline or processes
into the cloud.
If you are working with small data sets on
small machines, all of this can be free for
you.
definitely don't be worried about this.
If you need to get data out of the cloud that
is called egress and you should only be egress
and things that are the results of your analysis.
That is much smaller in size than other raw
data or meta files you might generate between
different tools.
If you are ready to get started, we made videos
available on how to start an instance on Amazon
and Google so check out our YouTube channel
for that.
https://tinyurl.com/SRAonthecloud
We have also provided help documentation for
all of this information in terms of getting
started with computing and some example queries
for big query.
You can find all of this in our help documentation.
https://tinyurl.com/SRAcloudDoc
Now that I introduce the tools, we are always
looking for more feedback from the scientific
community.
Reach out to us and tell us if something works
or doesn't work for you.
that's more important.
If we know what is not working we can try
to fix it and make the tools better for you.
the more feedback we get on anything either
for SRA or NCBI, we will take the feedback
and improve resources to meet your needs.
If you want to continue following NCBI and
what we are releasing into the cloud you can
follow the NCBI insights blog where we will
post more information about upcoming new functionality.
We also send out messages on Twitter and you
can follow NCBI for that.
SRA is also registered with Amazon open data
registry so you can find us there as well.
That is about it.
I can now open the floor to any questions
that you might have.
[Peter] This is Peter.
We have some questions in the chat pod.
Then I think you were going to do a demonstration
of BigQuery if we have time.
Someone did ask about that one.
First other simpler ones.
Somebody asked the question about your sequences
that are submitted to ENA, the European Nucleotide
Archive, so I think we basically get the sequences
into SRA and they would wind up on the cloud,
is that not true?
[Yuriy] That is true.
Since SRA is part of the INDSC, everything
that is part of SRA is also in the cloud as
well.
[Peter] Another one that is similar in spirit,
they were asking whether SRA is mirrored or
split.
I believe it is mirrored in both places.
You can get it on either platform.
Is that correct?
[Yuriy] That's correct.
Depending on your needs, you can use either
platform.
[Peter] One other simpler one although it
is a sensitive topic because we don't like
to talk directly about the cost that we've
experience from the government point of view
but can you comment on the compute cost associated
with contig creation?
[Yuriy] It's a difficult topic to answer.
I don't know the certain number but probably
several thousands of dollars were tens of
thousands of dollars.
In terms of computation.
I don't know how that would relate to anybody
else's expenses.
Concerning the amount of data we processed
and how fast we processed it, I think it was
a good expense for us.
[Peter] Thank you.
I guess the other question was, somebody was
asking about using BigQuery and the metadata.
You have a demo you could do with that.
That might be useful to do if you have time.
[Yuriy] I can do that.
The easiest way to find BigQuery is to do
a Google search for it.
Once you are here if you don't have a Google
account you will probably need to create it.
From here it is simple.
You can go to the console page.
This is the web interface that Google provided
for their service for BigQuery.
I think it's intuitive . You can see your
query history and the saved queries you've
run and some other options.
In order to connect to the SRA data
I find it easier to pin our project.
I will open my project here.
Go to the add data section and click on it.
There is a pin a project selection.
Our project is called NIH-SRA-data store.
So I type that in and click on the pin button.
Let's try that again.
I think I had a typo.
I may be typing something wrong.
But once you add the data store you can look
at what is available.
But I will use one of our Saved queries to
find some runs for you.
I can click on open query in editor.
And click run.
In order to use open query you will need to
learn SQL.
We have some example queries available on
documentation pages so you can copy those
to get started.
There is a lot of useful tutorials online
for using sequel and learning sequel.
To get started and it's not very hard.
I have a more complex query here but as you
saw, I ran the query and the results came
back in seconds.
You can see that I selected different type
of runs.
Either from DDBJ for this one and this was
submitted to SRA.
I displayed some columns that may be useful
to me such as the number of spots used in
them and percent unidentified reads.
Between the performance of big query and the
ability to write your own queries and customize
the results, this is a very useful tool for
pipeline developers or even if you just want
to get access to the data quickly, you can
use the web interface to search for your data
sets.
I think it is a powerful tool that can be
very beneficial.
[Peter] Thank you Yuriy, we have a few more
questions . There are three of them or four
of them actually that we should address.
Someone asked, is there an SRA docker container
store for toolkit and another apps.
[Yuriy] SRA will be releasing a Docker image
with the SRA toolkit.
It is in our roadmap to put that on Docker
hub so that will be coming soon.
NCBI has a Docker hub account where you can
look for other products that NCBI supports.
Please check out NCBI at the Docker hub.
[Peter] I have a question that is general
and should probably be addressed.
It has to do with what data are publicly accessible
and I think it's worth talking about the difference
between the controlled access data and the
data that is not controlled access.
And what do you have to do to get to those
things.
[Yuriy] Right.
We have public data that's available right
now.
For controlled access, human data, you would
need to get access to that data set through
dbGaP first.
That data is available in the cloud as well.
If you have access to datasets through dbGaP
you can access them in the cloud.
[Peter] Thank you.
Another question.
Has to do with the contigs and you mentioned
that they should be available before too long.
How soon do you think they will be available?
[Yuriy] The contigs for metagenomic data sets
are available now.
I think I added the link to the documentation
for them into the presentation, but if it
is not there, I will make sure to send out
the link to the documentation for them after
the presentation.
And the contigs are available in both Amazon
and GCP.
[Peter] The other question is about the compute
cost per assembly but I think you addressed
that when you talked about cost when we were
doing this for the contigs.
[Yuriy] Unfortunately I can't answer the question
of cost per assembly.
I can certainly get in touch with whoever
asked that question to talk to you more off-line
about that topic.
[Peter] That's a good idea.
You can write into the webinars address if
you want to.
Webinars at ncbi.nlm.nih.gov.
And someone else asked can you show an example
of doing an assembly in the cloud.
For a particular SRR.
[Yuriy] Doing assemblbly in the cloud is not
any different than running assembly at your
local server.
You use the same tools as you would there
as well.
The only difference is that instead of running
it at local server that you have available
to you or your desktop, you are doing it on
a server located in the cloud.
The process itself is not any different.
In this case I would be calling up an assembler
and providing data to it.
I don't have a demo available at this moment
but I'm sure that SRA can make a demo of that
and share it.
[Peter] Okay.
Another question which I think you addressed
this.
In some ways this webinar was about this topic,
but it is probably worth reiterating.
What is the advantage of using an ec2 instance
instead of using my own computer, basically
using the could instead of this person's own
computer.
Maybe there are a couple of points to you
share.
[Yuriy] Yes.
If you are downloading data using the toolkit,
it usually pulls data from our servers but
that is also where everybody around the world
is accessing the data you so are competing
for resources.
In the cloud it scales basically automatically.
You get faster access to the data there as
well.
Also if you need more powerful computers not
available locally, you have those machines
available in the cloud as well.
As I said, we had those bigger machines that
had 96 cores and lots of RAM.
Those might be harder to get locally for you
but they are available to you easily on the
cloud architecture.
Those are the benefits of doing that where
you get faster access to data and more powerful
computes.
If you move your pipelines and processes there
you can see it speed up in the overall analysis.
[Peter] Thank you.
Good question and a good way to seal things
to give the main advantages of doing this.
We mention access to the conttigs now available.
Is it easy for you to show us how to get access?
[Yuriy] Sure.
Here I'm going to the virus discovery github
page.
There is a readme on how to get access.
We provide instructions of how you would want
to download the contigs.
In this case if you are somewhere in the cloud,
either Google or Amazon, you can run either
AWS s3 copy command and download the conttig
file to your processing area in Amazon, there
are similar commands with gsutils for Google.
You can even run a wget command from a cloud
instance running at Amazon to download the
data.
That is all it takes, is running the one command
to download one of the contig fasta files.
[Peter] Okay.
That's great.
Somebody said we have one more.
Just a second.
This is an interesting one.
We may not be able to address it directly.
This is about the data from GISAID and does
that data get reflected in SRA.
It is relevant for the coronavirus data.
It seems to be submitted to GISAID.
[Yuriy] Right.
Unfortunately I don't believe we have that
data available at SRA.
We are certainly exploring options on how
to get access to that data.
It would be a publicly available item.
[Peter] Okay.
I think that is all the questions we have.
If there is any we didn't get to we will address
them in the documents we will produce.
I think we can wrap this up.
Thank you everyone for coming.
And thank you, Yuriy.
[Yuriy] Thank you.
[ Event Concluded ]